okay before I start the podcast I know
this is weird cuz I'm not saying what's
going on I just got to let you guys know
I got a big tour coming up this year and
all the pre-sales for most of my shows
are going on sale a special password has
been created for podcast listeners to
get tickets first use the code Billy
Baldwin you get it Baldwin
all capitals bi lly b al d wi n it's
active now midnight on Sunday Eastern
Standard Time and the public sale will
be Friday March 9th 12 p.m. all links
will be on Billboard com soon I will be
in Atlanta Georgia San Francisco Dublin
Ireland London England
for my 50th birthday Minneapolis Detroit
Portland Oregon Seattle Houston Dallas
Las Vegas Maryland Virginia Charleston
South Carolina Inglewood California
Denver Boston Baltimore Atlantic City
Chicago more dates to come jump on the
website and whatever used to use the
what a [ __ ] do you go I guess we're
gonna have links on all this [ __ ] right
that's right there'll be on the website
I'm sorry alright so check that out my
tour for 2018 and once again thank you
to everybody who's playing on coming out
to my shows I appreciate it and now
here's the podcast hey what's going on
it's Bill Byrne it's time for the Monday
morning podcast from Monday I'm gonna go
with what's today Thursday well 1st 2nd
3rd 4th 5th March 5th March 6th you
asking the wrong person I know I'm
asking the wrong person I'm recording
this on March 1st very special guests on
the podcast we've had two in a row 2
special guests in a row which means my
podcast continues to get more and more
special as I dropped the [ __ ]
recorder we have the great al Jerguson
from ministry right here he's got a new
album coming out and for whatever reason
he wanted to come on my stupid podcast
to promote it one of the legends of
really last 30 years basically you
invented an entirely new kind of music
right you were credited with coming up
with what they call an industrial
something like something like that I
just think it was I probably a bad
strain of acid in the nineteen you were
getting credit all the way back into the
80s though were you well yeah that was
the good strain of acid the 90s kind of
went downhill but what is what is the
Golden Age of acid would you say the 60s
definitely when when they finally
figured out the the DMT compounds that
were inorganic plants and were able to
make it chemically that was the golden
age because it was pure and before it
hit the streets and they cut it with
strychnine and baby aspirin and whatever
else right over cotton I mean I lived
with Timothy Leary for two years out
here in Jesus Christ well you survived
not only got survived I can't wait for
the book to come out because what you do
is he would just have me inject like
psychedelic compounds that were sent to
him by universities around the world and
then he'd take notes on me as the guinea
pig as University's code for the CIA
what was it actually like University so
wait so how huh well how do you meet a
guy and how does he bring up hey you
want to live with me for a while and
while you don't pay rent I'm just going
to occasionally inject you with some
acid I got through the mail that's
allegedly from a university well the
story of I wound up with Tim is actually
better than me being with Tammuz I met
Tim through William Burroughs which
wasn't a story on how I met William
Burroughs and we did a video we played
wide receiver for the Houston orbs was
no I was Canberra I know he's had one of
the beat writers that I never read did
he write Naked Lunch yeah he wrote naked
we did yes am amongst other things
Nova Express yeah the guy was a genius
and we wound up working with him because
basically because we sampled some of his
spoken word and Warner Brothers wouldn't
release our record at the time was Psalm
69 I believe there's early not
and they wouldn't release it and they
said well we can't get clearance for
this and so it was a little blurb in
random notes in Rolling Stone that said
ministry album postponed for another
year until they can figure this out
and then the Burroughs people called me
and said nobody asked us we'd be happy
to give you this [ __ ] man
oh wow you know hey when do you want to
work you want to do some other stuff
they were all happy about it so then I
wound up hanging out with Bill and
Kansas well when did the album come out
then so they didn't have to shell the
food shelf for about three months but it
wasn't like the year that they were
saying and all this and then we got
clearance and then William Bill
Burroughs introduced me to Timothy Leary
during that Lollapalooza tour and then
out to the Lollapalooza tour was done I
was kind of sick of rock music so I just
wanted to take a year or two off because
it was just it was just really gross it
was just you know all the after parties
and all this stuff it just it just gets
old after a while so wasn't the music
that was happening at the time it was
just you were burned out from all the
partying and all everything so I moved
in with the psychedelic master of all
time to get my head together
oh it's trying to picture how this this
was gonna work like I was sick of the
partying so I moved in with Timothy
Leary so you could experiment on me with
like acid and [ __ ] all right
you know you know who owns the the notes
that he took on all of my trips because
this is a weekly thing so you're [ __ ]
tripping and this guy's just looking at
you taking notes in the corner I never
dropped acid is that how you could say
no no no I injected it no sorry
like a [ __ ] lab rat okay he objected
cuz he knew I was a junkie at the time I
haven't done drugs in 15 years by the
way except for psychedelics I haven't
done heroin and coke and all that crap
and why psychedelics it's a cheap and
easy way to to get to what people would
call enlightenment as opposed to like
doing it through yoga and stretching
meditation that just takes too long this
just cuts to the quick and you're right
there where all the pee you know that's
why I don't like we'd really versus
alcohol
I feel like alcohol you earn it you know
you got to get it down the hatch you
make the face and like we especially the
[ __ ] they got now it's like you take two
or three talks and then you sit down and
it's like you're borderline tripping I
just don't feel like I earned it it's
like it I feel like a trust one kid
well I'll say this I mean as far as like
textiles in the modern age all right
this is cutting in and now this is my
shitty thing I think I can't move too
much all right sorry it's one of the few
things that have actually improved over
these recent years is the quality of pot
and obviously the quality of electronics
thanks to like stolen alien technology
or whatever the [ __ ] we got going right
yeah the quality of pot has improved to
the point to where it's almost like you
used to really get stoked for like a
weekend of mushrooms and now it's like
you smoke pot every day and it's just
like the weekend of mushrooms is just
like it's kind of the same thing yeah
the pots improved especially out here
I've never taken mushrooms either
I don't done any of the loosen let's see
though this weekend I want to do that I
think basically I think it's just my
headphones that it keeps cutting in and
out but I'm watching the little bubbles
here and they keep going up like I'm
talking so you seem good yeah
okay cool well you know there's a lot of
people out there like myself that have
never tried any of this [ __ ] so what
what is it like to be on on mushrooms
I'm never gonna do it maybe when I get
like my kid grows up and goes out of the
house I don't want to do it in a hacky
way like go to [ __ ] Josh Joshua Tree
be like hey man like look at the rock
formation oh no don't do that
but I want to go to Best Buy and get
like lost you cannot look at me scream
you you need to be a veteran at that
point you don't go into a mall with like
fluorescent lights or a shop like Home
Depot or Lowe's unless you're an
experienced Ripper okay that's when
incidents happen so if you go in there
and you've done this a few times you
find
yourself smirking at the absurdity of
places like Lowe's or Home Depot right
strip malls or things like this but if
you go in there first time and do that
this you're freaking they're gonna dig
my grave yeah
now the first time I actually I think
actually was tripping a little bit was I
ingested weed and then went to the
airport to board an international flight
night two and a half plot brownies and I
was just too much and yeah it was way
too much and I know I did some sort of
brain damage and I just never [ __ ]
with it again I just it felt like I had
you know like I told this story an Opie
and Anthony long time ago you know like
when your foot falls asleep really bad
it felt like there was a ball of that
like just sitting on my head like you
know those those those things you use in
the shower those big puffy things it
felt like there was like that size of it
just sitting right on the crown of my
head and it was like we'd hung over for
like two days dude I went to Costa Rica
and I got off and out I thought it was
going to get arrested all I was thinking
was like Midnight Express and all that
[ __ ] but yes I just I was like booze
because you know I was a corny kid and
in my world it was legal you know like
it's not a drug man it's legal it's a
simple high - it's just I'm a simple guy
oh there's a spot for alcohol in one's
life I would I would assume but yeah it
gets a bit more complex with
psychedelics and weed and [ __ ] like this
and and heroin and at first you know is
really actually it's a psychedelic at
first and then it becomes a day to day
dragon routine which you're not using
the drug that drug is using you all
these great cliches blah blah blah how
long does that take
when is the honeymoon over with heroin
Oh well technically looking back on my
days a couple decades of doing that I
would say after the very first hit
really oh no and then you spend the next
20 years trying to recreate that first
hit now are you able to like try
heroin right this is so bad for kids
listening we were able to try heroin and
walk away from it is can people try it
and walk away from it just bit you know
I did it I just yeah I think I think
there are and especially because the
first time you do it generally it it
consumes the body so much that you're
just so not used to this kind of like
forced almost Hyperloop tunnel into the
unknown that you'd throw up a lot of
people walk their first time it's a you
get like airsick as you're teleporting
into another reality seriously it's it's
like that I mean it's a lot of people
like I remember the first time I got
wrong I was like eight years old my
parents had some kind of like sixties
kind of Tiki themed cocktail party
further my sounds like Drew Barrymore's
childhood somebody gives you an 8-ball
let's get him Oneg ball twelve great
parents yeah I went around and like
emptied all the drinks that people have
left at this Tiki themed party my
parents I was about eight and I think
they're mainly drinking like some kind
of gin based late gins and evil oh it's
evil gin it's just anything I drink that
and I got so violently sick that I never
wanted to drink liquor again but here I
am I mean I still drink liquor it's the
same thing with heroin it's like their
first time you're gonna probably get
sick because your body's overwhelmed it
doesn't so you the sort of a loose I
always sort of just made you super
relaxed like my only idea of it was in
Trainspotting when that guy shot up and
the we just fell into the rug and sunk
into the floor yeah which Akshay I was
like wow that looks so amazing yeah yeah
like I just can't deal with the side
effects I mean that scene and get out
we're like the lady hits the the
teaspoon on the cup and then floats down
in the chair the black dude I mean you
also have trips like that on how on
heroin is actually an opiate I mean
Aleister Crowley and even Lord Byron
from like the 18th century they used to
dabble in opiates morphine back then and
just like whoa you know and there's bad
trips and good trips but it is trip so
except that a lot of the times you're
not awake
during the trip all right it's more like
a controlled or uncontrolled dreamscape
that you're having even more
uncontrolled than usual because how do
your legs feel afterwards like whenever
I'm back in the day when New York was
New York and like every you know tenth
corner there would be a junkie just
nodding out on heroin
I remember Marc Maron uses this
hilarious bit about how they never tip
over or something like that but like oh
yeah and the thing was but they would be
in like doing like the longest squad
ever you know what I mean you know if
you do like a set of tennis squats like
your [ __ ] thighs at burn it's like
how does that feel that's that's what I
would think I wouldn't think man this
guy's [ __ ] his life up it's minus 30
out he has no coat on and he's just
standing there slowly going down on the
ground like how do you legs how do you
yeah all right what do they feel like
afterwards ask yourself this man let's
say transport yourself to the Amazon
jungle
you got sloths there right that sit
there and hang on this one branch for
like days that are talking right those
things only poop like once a week I'm
thinking about getting one as a pet so
when I go on tour it's and I just put a
diaper on them and I come home and I
don't have to clean anything up so I
move three feet over it's the same thing
as being a junkie very much like a sloth
and and I'll say this much for sloths
you can get some all you want but
they've been around for over three
million years now is there a group of
people out there just trashing slots I
just like how you said you can just you
can talk [ __ ] about amalia oil I've seen
it I've seen it on the interwebs where
like people are like downright bashing
sloths I'm like such a sad world well
well that's capitalism that's America
it's like we don't like sloths we like
go-getters you know if you count your
fat [ __ ] I'm trying to make money off
you that's what that's what a sloth is
like being a junkie and yes you can do
superhuman feats of hang on a tree
branch for three days I'm going to squat
position you probably thought like you
know what you're in an hour
you're high out of your [ __ ] mind on
heroin and you go I gotta take a [ __ ]
and you probably start the squat in
about three days later you finally
finish something [ __ ] well you know the
one thing that the one good side effect
of heroin seems to be if you survive is
you're kind of in shapes borderline
shredded for the rest of your life what
is that I every [ __ ] guy that every
rocks I've ever seen that they had a ten
year period on heroin
they're like 70 they have like 0% body
fat they still have abs if it wasn't for
their old skin hanging off of them they
could model underwear man you just
described me perfect no I asked Williams
what the [ __ ] is going on around here no
they'll leave blowing Jesus I don't even
know who that guy is so you sure he's
the leaf blower he's I think he's from
Terminator vibes probably hi breaks into
houses that's his thing he just walks
around the leafblower
William Burroughs at 78 looked like he
did at 18 which at 18 he looked like he
was 78 but always they never changed
after right it was like this weird
pickling and all those porn addicts get
that then getting pickled I not only was
I on heroin but of course I was on the
methadone program for 18 years invented
by the Nazis you know another thing to
be you know a little wrinkle on your
face dude hilarious but all this [ __ ]
you did I'm [ __ ] pickled and it's
been 15 years since I even touched this
[ __ ] I so basically I heard your podcast
last week bitching about like oh you're
50 and you let me tell you the next 10
years cuz I'm gonna be turning 60 this
year you're in [ __ ] Phil now man no I'm
going sting in my 50s no I don't care
about God are you trying to oh god [ __ ]
no no no you treat me like a sloth right
now I resent it you're [ __ ]
I mean just look I get up and I ride 20
miles a day on a stationary tell
everybody what you watch when you're
doing do you men what you were telling
me they should wear last time I talked
to you the show the reality show you
used to watch when you would oh oh
that's 600 pound life so you'd sit there
watch and I mean my wife started watch
this I was like Mia you have to shut
this off because I
much biggest loser funny fat yeah but
they have funny fat and they shower
scenes 600-pound life as soon as they
focus in on a girl named Kirsten or
something then the next seven minutes
are her taking off her clothes and
getting into a shower it's literally fat
core porn on TV I know and the thing is
they don't have like like with the guys
they don't have to blur out anything
like their fat covers right it's like
they have they have like a [ __ ]
speedo made out of fat oh I saw this one
guy he was like leaned up against the
wall in the shower and his stomach hung
all the way down to his [ __ ] ankles I
mean yeah oh my god then they come in
and the wife will come in and she has
like you know let that you know that
do-it-yourself car wash oh they got that
scrub brush they do we have one hand is
lifting up a roll of fat and she's just
and the guys in there like uh like it's
like he's trying to hold up a
refrigerator but it's something that's
himself I love that show that and I'll
ride every day to either 600-pound life
or body bizarre which isn't know what is
that oh that's that's things where
people have tails and eight legs
joined-at-the-hip
two heads Oh like birth defects yeah
yeah and what are they calling in body
bizarre you got it they want PT Barnum a
like okay birth defects I don't feel
like people are gonna watch it if we
call that totally it's the only thing to
ride to if you want to do an exercise
program just like watch that [ __ ] and
ride and just you feel better about like
trying to do something for yourself you
know it's just like wow these people
have really gone to [ __ ] I'm kickin ass
I would love to hear them brainstorming
for that show weird bodies now now let's
get a literation going body Bonanza body
bizarre bunny bizarre that's yeah I
don't know I don't know I actually
dropped some weight since the last time
I saw you you look good I've been trying
to [ __ ] drag that compliment out of
you like I laid off the booze for like
four months and now I've been like
trying to eat
staying away from the breads and all
that gluten [ __ ] it I actually you know
as much as that's a big Hollywood thing
I feel a lot better but every once in a
while I'll [ __ ] you know I'll eat a
pizza and it's delicious I could never
just like totally walk away like what
I'm never gonna have a pizza again and
I'm not gonna eat that stupid
gluten-free one that's like fat Dan this
gluten-free what is what what is that I
mean it's like Wladimir gluten that's
all I know is all my friends are there
dictator I just know I'm losing weight
doing it and I eat that Ezekiel bread
which just tastes like ass I mean it's
really just like it's like if you took
bread and stuck in a microwave and all
the nutrients left but you know if you
put enough [ __ ] on it if you put a
little almond butter on it it does taste
good and I am losing weight I don't know
but I feel like I'm still eating salads
and [ __ ] it's like I'm Emily people
people run like that but what is that
diet where it's like dude I could eat
bacon all day as long as I don't eat
this and it's just like yeah Atkins diet
yeah they had a car yeah no carbs no
cars yeah it spawned a whole beer
industry of Lokar beer yes like [ __ ] out
a cow head at the end of the [ __ ]
horns and all I remember my watching my
friends doing that I just never think
like that can't be good like just eating
meat all the [ __ ] time like they
didn't seem like they were eating salads
they were just sitting there that we'd
like eating bacon and like Turkey and
not saying any of that shit's bad
because who knows at this point this
guy's out there that's sick and now like
they're putting melted butter into their
coffee I know
no but they're saying that like that all
of that saturated fat [ __ ] that they
were saying is now a myth it's like it's
like the egg in my lifetime the egg many
times is the egg been in and out and out
and ever the month or not it's like John
Travolta's career - John Travolta
[ __ ] Saturday Night Fever Sweathogs
all right then he [ __ ] went away in
the 80s that he came back with Pulp
Fiction then he did [ __ ] Battlefield
Earth and I don't he's doing now but I
feel like he's gonna come back again you
know what I'm actually one of the few
people that dude this is embarrassing
this is probably the most embarrassing
thing you're gonna get me to say on this
putt I love it is I actually liked
Battlefield Earth oh you did I never saw
it I
forced Whitaker's in it for God's sake
berry peppers in it berry peppers none
of these guys want us to mention that
those are all great actors yeah great
actors and it was written by l ron
hubbard which is basically the same
thing that this ancient aliens guy
Zecharia Sitchin wrote in his book the
12th planet about how we've been
colonized for four hundred thousand
years starting in South Africa where
they took Apes and genetically made them
into like gold mine workers because they
needed gold dust to protect their plant
of the ozone on their planet or some
kind of crazy [ __ ]
either way it's totally believable to me
I mean I don't care one way or the other
but but that included with all those
good actors and this kind of tie into
sounds like Star Wars mixed with roots
mixed with mushrooms makes mushrooms
there you go I actually like Battlefield
Earth uh I remember every boy so that's
what that movie was about yeah yeah it
was like a colonizing dumbass humans
which they just made from apes through
their DNA and and had them all like
mining gold for him because they needed
the gold on their home planet and this
and that and John Travolta had dreads
just like I got now it was like no I'm
thinking that movie was pretty cool and
I remember getting a lot of [ __ ] for it
going I'm all for this movie at the time
and now it's like okay I'm interestingly
admitting that Lots really interesting
the plot is interesting so wait the
Scientologists think that we came from
apes
I thought they throws some sort of
spaceship oh yeah yeah there's a
spaceship that comes down and they
needed they tried to have their own
people mind these gold mines and these
people just said [ __ ] you I want to go
back to my home planet this is [ __ ]
work man this is like this is like
working as a barista at Starbucks or
Donald's and so get these Apes to do it
that are already on the planet and so
they genetically engineered them to be a
little bit smarter and then they started
mining the gold and those guys could
hang out and drink so is that where my
tax money is going yeah he's going to
another planet black projects man black
projects are all over the place
what are black projects you know all the
[ __ ] like
Jones is on about everyday except he's
way off the mark but just like what what
they don't think that guy's had the nail
on the head over there he's swinging big
swing a big over there I was in the
major leagues his batting average would
be about 139 I know but when he connects
but when it connects they know it's
leaving the park that's why you go you
you want to see a guy swinging like that
out of right out of his [ __ ] cleats
that's it I can't listen I used to be
into all of that [ __ ] and like I see you
got what are we watching here MSNBC and
I like how they walk around now when
they do in the news to add some level of
excitement to it ESPN does it they all
[ __ ] they all walk around I don't
watch any of this [ __ ]
all right first read of the week here in
dough cheeto talked about how
made-to-measure suits compared to
generic off-the-rack suits well unless
you're the exact same size is a
mannequin which most people aren't it's
just an impossible body image it's not
going to fit right so if you get it made
to measure you're gonna look great
endo Chino is the largest custom apparel
company that makes suits and shirts made
to your exact measurements for a great
fit guys love the wide selection of high
quality fabrics and the options to
personalize to all the details including
lapel jacket lining monogram and much
much more
here's how it work works you pick your
fabric choose your customization submit
your measurements place your order and
wait for it to arrive in three weeks or
less you can shop at Indo Chino comm or
visit any of their showrooms across
North America this week my listeners can
get any premium Indo Chino suit but
three hundred fifty nine bucks at
indochina calm when entering burp you
are at checkout that's over 50% off the
regular price for premium
made-to-measure suit plus shipping is
free that's Indochina com promo code bar
for any premium suit just three and
fifty nine dollars plus free shipping
incredible deal for a perfectly tailored
suit Indo Chino IND o CH i n oh look
who's here it's our old friends old zip
crooner are you hiring well
posting your position to job sites and
waiting and waiting for the right people
to see it
zip recruiter knew there was a smarter
way so they built a platform that finds
the right job candidate for you zip
learns that you're looking for learns
what you're looking for identities of
people with the right experience and
invites them to apply to the job these
invitations have revolutionized how you
find your next hire in fact 80% of
employees who post on zip get a quality
candidate through the site in just one
day and zip recruiters doesn't stop
there
they even spotlight the strongest
applications you receive so you never
miss a great match that's right
candidate the right candidates are out
there zip recruiter is how you find them
call to action businesses of all sizes
trust zip for their hiring needs right
now my listeners can try zip for free
that's right free you just go to zip
guru.com slash bar that zip recruiter
com / / zip recruited dot-com / bar.com
the smartest oh look who's back it's our
old friends old Dollar Shave Club dude
jolly shake club is better than shopping
and is so jolly Shave Club delivers to
you everything you need to look smell
and feel your best shampoo Body Wash
toothpaste and of course the best razors
I have ever used I get an amazing
high-quality shave every morning from my
Dollar Shave Club executive but the true
hero of my morning routine has to be
that dr. Cobb is easy shape it helps a
razor gently a crop glide across your
skin please don't use this as on your
balls you have to experience it another
must have experienced is how Dollar
Shave Club delivers everything to you
that means no more trips to the store
wandering the aisles hunting for razors
shampoo toothpaste and having to play at
being a cashier scanning and bagging
your own stuff [ __ ] all that [ __ ] for a
mind-blowing experience just join Dollar
Shave Club today and for just 5 dollars
with free shipping you'll get the 6
executive razor plus trial sizes of
shave butter body cleanser and one white
cheese then keep the blades coming for a
few bucks more a month get yours at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / okay lastly but
of course not least stamps calm
everybody the US Postal Service is an
important tool for any business reaching
every household every day stamps.com
brings all the amazing services of the
US Postal Service right to your
fingertips by in print official US
postage for any letter any package any
class of mail using your own computer
and printer stamps calms makes it easy
they'll send you a digital scale
automatic that automatically calculates
the exact postage stamps comm will even
help you decide the best class of mail
based on your needs no need to leased an
expensive postage meter and there are no
long term commitments I use stamps comm
whenever I gonna sell posters whatever
hell I do at the end of my shows and I'm
a [ __ ] if I can figure out how to help
to send these goddamn things out so can
you and right now you can enjoy the Stan
starcom service with the special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale go to stamps
com click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in bur that
stamps comm enter ber okay and that's
the ad reads and now back to the podcast
dean always talk to the other day on my
podcast like I was at Wilshire and the
405 right there there was a bunch of
like pro-second amendment people just
standing and they just were yelling
america love it or leave it right and I
just like the whole thing that's
fascinating to me is that you know these
guys wrote this amendment way back in
the day and it's just like what [ __ ]
does evolve I mean it was an amendment
so they weren't they that was a change
to what already existed and like you do
have to it just cuz I don't have I don't
know cuz I don't have a problem with
guns problem
argument right away is there on the
corner yelling America love it or leave
it so they obviously don't love it
because they're on a corner at [ __ ]
405 and Wilshire yelling so they don't
love it so why don't they leave it you
know it just because Norway doesn't
[ __ ] want them oh alright I don't
know what I don't that's why do they not
have guns out there in Norway how do
they keep their people under control
no guns I know I'd look I don't have a
yeah I don't think there's anything
wrong with guns if you [ __ ] own them
responsibly they just have to figure out
a way if they could just figure out a
[ __ ] way to make sure that these
[ __ ] lunatics who then go on social
media saying I'm gonna do this [ __ ] and
everybody kind of ignores it off hey man
it's it's a simple if you get a couple
duis they take your license away right
if you're going to get a gun and you've
had a couple batteries assaults domestic
[ __ ] all sorts of crappy stuff and you
tortured animals as a child and you've
been thrown out of five schools probably
not a good idea to get a gun I have
nothing against guns either I mean look
you know if you're some Grizzly Adams
type living in a cabin in Colorado
shootin grizzly bears for hides food
tent sustenance this and that good on
you
you know you're probably a responsible
gun owner oh he's good he's gonna create
the next people in guys that let's all
goes to [ __ ] got beat up too much in
high school they weren't part of the
cool clique they start making threats on
YouTube this and that and the other they
beat up their wife their girlfriends
this and that they beat up their moms
they you know don't give them a [ __ ]
gun yeah I've joined a band yeah get
into show business like the rest of us
well speaking of that before we get all
sideways here with the politics I can't
[ __ ] hear myself anymore hey let me
take this out put it back and come on
you best today where is it where's the
sweet spot there is you got a new album
coming up oh yeah right tell us tell us
the name tell us about it I listen to
one track
I love the harmonic on at that haunting
like with it with the reverb on it and
stuff
I don't know whatever the name of the
track was but maybe what made me eagle
Twilight Zone it made me want to go play
drums that's how I know I like a song is
I immediately go into fantasy mode and
whatever cool thing is happening I'm
doing it so at first I was playing drums
and then when you did the whole Monica
part then that was me and my fantasy I
was playing that and everybody was
gazing up at the stage going wow look
how awesome bill is so you're wonderful
one that could still happen okay now and
we've all heard you to come on stage
before and you pussied out well I am
[ __ ] out what are you talking about
that danza get that well I couldn't make
it down there no this is thing dude if
you want look like we were ready to
bring you a helicopter to fly down on
the stage and have you come back and
play drums fry now that you said I'm a
[ __ ] I'll do it I'm playing a little
bit of double bass now I just don't know
ruin it I don't want to ruin it because
people are coming there to see you like
and you know what's - because you were
doing a festival so I figure you played
a shorter set yeah like if you're going
then it's a full-on you show if you have
some jerk-off comic come on for one song
I think the crowd can handle that but if
it's just like hey we only got time for
six songs and on one of them the guy
from vh1's I love the eighty strikes
back is going to play drums now I know
you guys might get a kick out of that
I'm just worried that your fans like
what they're gonna [ __ ] throw at me
when I'm up there you know what my
favorite guest appearance for us of all
time was during Lollapalooza we had Kirk
Hammett from Metallica oh wow come on
stage we'd known Kirk for a while and
we'd opened up for Metallica on a bunch
of dates in Europe and so we got to be
friends and Kirk came out and we did a
cover of a Black Sabbath song called
super not at a festival and we're
playing it and we gave him the second
lead in the song so he started going
crazy
I mean his hair was flying it looked
like he had one of those industrial blow
dryers on his hair and there was a blow
dryer just his hair was flinging around
into it he was into it and all that but
it just went on for [ __ ] ever and so
the rest of the band was just like well
[ __ ] it we're out of here so we all just
walked off
but by the time he realized what's
happening he's still in the middle of
his lead there's no band members up
there and we're all standing there on
the side of the stage like looking at
our watches going dude really this is
now like going on a 12 minute solo you
[ __ ] Oh No so then wait what at that
point he told me later it's like he
didn't want to leave the stage because
he realized he was gonna get [ __ ] when
he left so he might as well keep going
at that point I think it wound up to be
like a 17 minutes so loudly he's gonna
get his ass beat on this one of the
things if you guys leave and then he
doesn't leave it looks like it's planned
right well it wasn't planned we were
just bored Jesus Christ
well now what is the etiquette if
somebody goes to sis you know 5e you
better not [ __ ] do that to me you
guys that would be hilarious stuff you
leave me out there and I'll be there
like I can do that before I get killed
that's when you start incorporating the
tom-toms that what I do what I would do
is I would just I would do a backward
somersault off the stool crawl my way
out underneath the curtain did he get
mad at you guys who do you think it was
funny no he was scared shitless but tell
me got off and then we all acted pissed
and that was like I that was fun man you
know and just that he was kind of scared
at first but he's never come back with
this ever since he just come back on
stage we don't get a lot of guest
artists anymore well I'm sure he told
that story I'm imagine that that went
around I don't know if we didn't want to
repeat that story it's pretty freaked
out I would have told it anyway so you
got this new album coming out when it
comes out on on was it March 6th when it
comes out March 9th 9th yeah that's a
Friday okay yeah shrooms that's right
shroom weekend and where can where can
people get it I guess everywhere I don't
know
oh god I mean what are you really
creative guys are the worst promote
Wilshire with a with a billboard and
start talking CDs I mean I don't know
where these things are sold well is it
gonna be ours old anymore they just like
you know by the time we post this I'm
sure someone will give me a link and
I'll be able to tell people where to get
it I mean I
you've been in this business long enough
that you know that the whole purpose of
this is to people don't care you're [ __ ]
man I've been in this business long
enough to also know that I don't really
give a [ __ ] about this part of the
business okay I just kind of like do
what I do and you know now you were
influenced like I always heard those
guys you were talking about Oh
bilborough's as you call it William
Burroughs right yeah didn't those guys
they would right type out a bunch a
whole page of the story and then they
would cut up all every word individually
they'd throw it in the air and then tape
it all together yeah
and then they would just start writing
from that ya know that that's what I did
on in 1980 well as a 88 or some [ __ ]
around like land of rape and honey I
decided to do an album like that based
on William Burroughs writing which is
how I hooked up with him later I just
took a bunch of pieces of tape yes we
actually use tape back then not just
digital and just cut it all up into
various pieces and threw it on the floor
spilled coffee on snorted coke off of
him or did whatever and then put them
back together somewhere backwards
somewhere forward some work some not and
then put it together and actually fold a
narrative which is what Bill Burroughs
was saying I almost did it as an
experiment to going this guy's crazy
that can't just happen like he just
throw [ __ ] random on the floor and it
talks to you but 90% of the time it
seemed to work like wow like he you
couldn't have done that yourself so it's
like you're you're throwing yourself to
like random chance of it coming out good
and sometimes it does how did you get
the balls to do that you got a record
deal and everybody else is trying so
hard to do it the way that everybody's
doing it you have the ability to do it
that way how did you get the balls to be
like that were you independent at that
point so you could take that kind of
risk just didn't care
I've done a couple Records for major
labels at that point I did this horrific
record where they took over the whole
thing out for heiress to Records then i
did this other record for Warner
Brothers that pretty much gave me carte
blanche but it was still like learning
to crawl before you walk by the time I
got to that record I was just sick of
all these people I figured like if these
are the people that claim to know what
they're doing then I must be [ __ ]
Einstein because these people are dull
I just decided to do whatever the [ __ ] I
wanted to do you know right so how did
you come up with what is what is that
song the [ __ ] worst
instead thing we stigmata the guitar
riff on that I always thought the guy
had a slide I've done a slide somebody
told me you sped it up that well I did
that too and I also added a didgeridoo
under that to get that slide I get
really meticulous how much that's one of
the sickest riffs of all time I played
that for my wife and she was like what
the [ __ ] is this this is awesome and
then you went one over the top and then
you know then she kind of left me well
back then people weren't using distorted
vocals either and that was actually
quite the accident because we had this
cheap Sony ass Mike that ran on
batteries and the batteries were low and
when I went to sing that first scream it
just sounded like a cat was being
tortured Mike it sounds great let's keep
it you know so we and then we started
trying to replicate that sound for the
next 10 years you know it's kind of like
your first heroin hit right next 10
years we should have kept that
microphone in those batteries so what
did you just use like the bullhorn cuz
I've seen like the clip see your live
shows are unbelievable and they're also
terrifying like I love them they give me
the chills as I'm watching it but then
there's a part of me going you know I'm
glad I wasn't in like that [ __ ] pit
down front because especially the way I
looked back then I look like [ __ ] Ron
Howard way back in the day before I look
like a it's ginger bread our pit is like
it's scary for us too we look these
[ __ ] kids and we're like you know
like like I said I'm pushing 60 and I'm
looking at these 20 year old kids and
I'm thinking like these could be
literally physically my grandkids and
I'm worried about our future it's not a
bit on stage man what's some of the
weirdest [ __ ] or scary [ __ ] you've seen
when you were on stage you know what no
I don't have anything that's like
particularly like like you know
about like what with there's some rap
concert the other day that they stopped
a concert because they saw a girl being
raped in the front row we're in the pit
or something like that and I've never
how does that happen like other people
don't see that there's so like what what
riff were they playing that everyone was
so locked into it that there's literally
somebody getting raped next to you and
you can't see it I don't know I don't
understand that I've never seen anything
like that actually some stairway
stairway to heaven maybe people love
that one just waiting for that drum fill
well that would be like it if I saw
something really weird on a stairway to
heaven song at a Led Zeppelin concert it
would probably be a hobbit being raped
in the pit because I never understood
this about Led Zeppelin don't take me
wrong I love the [ __ ] band but this
guy basically his lyrics we've given him
a pass all these things about is
dungeons dragons castles maidens horses
and his dick and his dick that squeeze
my lemon or whatever I mean this guy's
really coasted this rocky flank god yeah
and I love the [ __ ] band
don't take did you ever get to see them
oh yeah of course [ __ ] and they're just
amazing what what tours did you see him
on me page I saw him at the Chicago
Stadium and like what 75 76 77 something
like that I mean so Bonham had the Vista
light at that point right the orange
see-through one no he was strutting
around he's oh drunk
it gets better well while they were in
town okay they spent three days in
Chicago and he did his show at the
Chicago Stadium the old stadium and I
once saw that and then I had to work at
wax trax so no so this is like 79 so
he's got this stainless steel kid no no
he was walking around with like a little
like girly top tied off around mid torso
and
and good Robert Plant I think some
bottom I'll tell my bell-bottoms there
were as wide as this coffee table and
he's strutting around doing all the
stuff and at that point he's in his mid
to late 40s and I just thought like I
just thought dammit this is
inappropriate you know it's funny he
wasn't he was only like 30 or 31 he was
born in 48 mid 40s so maybe he should
have stuck to heroin because he wasn't
picking around and I'm going like that's
like he's doing like this chicken dance
and stuff on here and singing about
hobbits and and I immediately zoned out
and paid no attention and just listened
to like the tightness of the band and
and you could plant did get old quick
though he was like a young guy and then
right after Physical Graffiti he just
got all the lines in his face yeah yeah
that's weird I think that's genetic so I
think that's that that's kind of like a
Nordic thing I think he must be have
Nordic DNA because like that's what
happens to Scandinavian people they look
so awesome when they're young and then
because their genetics tell them like
when they're old they've spent 40 years
of Nordic winters and their skin says
[ __ ] you I'm cracking right wrinkling
now they just needed some lotion but he
looks cool now though he needs lotion
but he looks cool now though he looks
great now he found the lotion but he
never yeah but you can tell his face he
never did heroine yeah that's hilarious
you can look at old people tell the
drugs that they did well hey you're also
a lot of people might not know this
about you is you're a huge hockey fan
are they literally in the house building
[ __ ] right now
yeah okay this is destruction zone one
this is that's cool we've done we've
done almost 40 minutes before the
hammering started - no no and razing
part up Led Zeppelin hammer of the gods
oh right right there huh Jesus oh yeah
that was that was a book that put me to
sleep so I believed every word of it oh
I do too
I'm hoping to sleep it's compared to
like the [ __ ] we did and not only just
us I'm talking to you put
shark and son have been a woman there's
no what happened well with the Edgewater
and shark it was as a dolphin no no it
was a bathtub plastic shark and one of
our roadies was penetrating a girl
willingly there was no rape I was about
us how about Zeppelin
oh no I'm talking about our tour [ __ ]
that I've seen I've seen some crazy [ __ ]
I mean that's not [ __ ] random that is
that I sprouted bringing a shark putting
it in a woman who the [ __ ] does that and
you actually had a story you know I
wasn't a real shark it was a toy shark
well and it wasn't me and it wasn't the
banners we had two buses we had the road
crew boss and the ban shark bus and and
and the band bus basically had some kind
of decorum going on but the the crew bus
was literally Dante's Ninth Gate of Hell
I mean walk on there and it was just
like Caligula on steroids going on how
the [ __ ] that you'd see and I just go on
there because like say I am out of I'm
out of smokes I go in to borrow a pack
of smokes from one of the roadies cuz
none of the band smokes and so I go and
then I walk in and just walk into like
Dante's Inferno stepping through an orgy
get a human minefield of fornication try
not to step on anybody's [ __ ] heads
yeah well you know I'm actually uh I
I've had the exact opposite experience
on the road where it's just been a
lonely isolated thing but I was kind of
built for that like people somebody was
asking about that [ __ ] you know about
being on the road and like groupies and
stuff it's just like dude that just
doesn't [ __ ] it's different it
conflicted me it's just not it's not
what like do you guys go up there with a
[ __ ] ukelele and you just [ __ ]
Brown and all of a sudden there's
[ __ ] panties flying it you know it's
true I'm not saying you I'm not saying
you get but you know me I get bolts and
coins and bottles flying at me I don't
get panty I'm not stuck you know some
[ __ ] jerk-off could go to a goddamn
coffee house on an open mic all right
and he can [ __ ] go up there with the
ukulele it's he could literally do his
cover probably do a reggae version of a
momma and Popa song
oh the leaves a brown man right and the
next thing you know there's got some
woman is gonna [ __ ] a respond to it you
know yeah but how many people do you
travel with when you go on the road
nobody I go by myself I don't have a
handler though I like open it now it's
just more people I got to talk to I
don't have a look if I go to another
country and I don't mean Canada yeah I
mean another country I wait no when I
did Canada they gave like a road person
iives me up the [ __ ] wall but when
I'm in another country I loved it when I
was in Australia the guy I had was
[ __ ] awesome and I'm definitely gonna
use him again when I cover my bases here
something from the states with you know
he travel alone you just go yeah
Australia I'm going well if I'm going to
Australia what I love I love having a
tour manager because he shows up and
it's just like alright this is what you
need to be but I don't have to worry
about anything in this transportation
when I go into England I've had a great
people and all that type of stuff great
people to Scandinavian all that [ __ ] but
in the States
no I just show up on wool I get a
rent-a-car like [ __ ] Chuck Berry
drive up with my mic stand in the car
that keeps the overhead low that's the
thing that's that's where things get
dicey when like our our touring party is
about 17 people between bed and crew and
there's generally three or four rookies
on each tour and the rookies have read
too many books like hammer the gods or
Malo
and so they bring that that that [ __ ]
onto the bus is mainly on the crew bus
we haven't had we've had the most boring
band bus for probably about almost 1213
years thank God because you guys sit
there playing like cards against
humanity' like that's a crazy night you
know what no we we just we get the [ __ ]
off the bus we stay in our little areas
and get the [ __ ] off the bus and go to
the hotel as soon as possible and then
then our like stupid [ __ ] happens at the
hotel bar no watch on the bus the bus is
like kind of like this I'm a big hotel
bar guy I love it because it's like
you're already kind of home it's like
you downstairs in your own kitchen and
you can just drink down there and then
just he'll bar tenders are always like I
I don't even I think they're
psychologists they're good right at
least the hotels you stayed I would say
Sheratons Hilton's isn't that Radisson
smell of beer east and that's that kind
of [ __ ] those hotel bartenders in every
city are like they must have taken a
class because they're all real similar
they're all psychology Bryce drink
poured my favorite hotel bar is the one
you can you can be like staying on the
10th floor and you can look down over at
the elevator to see if it's still open
you know those ones rather than a half
of all the way down and you'll just see
these drunks sitting down there I'm
still going we gotta get going you don't
have to call anybody or anything like
that so hey is there a because I do want
to promote your album man I think you're
a [ __ ] genius so is there any sort of
theme on this one is it just yeah look
man I mean I've been known to bash our
right-wing friends before and our
right-wing leaders such as George Bush
and Ronald Reagan and things in the past
but this this one is not real anti-trump
it's more like what kind of system keeps
producing these people let's let's cut
to the quick here it's the system that
keeps producing these people that we
keep thinking is a good idea to be our
spokesperson for our ideals and and the
quality of these people keeps going down
and down and down so rather than it is
falling off where we at least we had low
bar we had like we used to have career
politician then we went to like the
boss's son yeah and now we've got like a
reality show like TV star and now which
is causing all these people out here in
Hollywood to go like I want to run like
the second you say you want to run for
president yeah you're out of your mind
you're basically saying you're saying I
want to have dead bodies on my
conscience because that's what the [ __ ]
you signing up for and I'm not saying
that you're gonna have to go out and do
the wrong thing but like in the process
of doing the right thing you're gonna
kill people that were just in the wrong
place that's why I think they aged the
way they do because it's like heavy yeah
[ __ ] heavy I get asked this question
all time and interviews all right mr.
political what would what's the first
thing you do if you were president I'd
[ __ ] quit you could I don't want any
part of this yet I put the solar panels
back on the White House and then I'd
leave okay personally I would do that
and I would get I'd have the gut this
chef there the chef make me a sandwich
and I want to ride in the helicopter and
then that's it I now introduce you to
the vice president and the person who
will now be running all of this [ __ ] you
got to throw one party in on Air Force
One one big ball it just kind of looks
like a giant like [ __ ] thing I always
flying the marine one helicopter always
look badass to me you're old enough to
remember it old 747 fleet ever fly a 747
I want you to you got to go
the Ronald Reagan Library I know they
have that they have they have literally
the one that he sat on talking to
Gorbachev forget to go upstairs to that
bar and hang out with the cool people
while you were flying that 747 I've
always wanted to I did that one time I
got busted twice and sent right back
down you know it was a spiral staircase
yes and you went and went up there and
everybody had suits and those [ __ ]
stewardesses well hot yeah I when we
were I did this just run through Asia I
did the [ __ ] that I Singapore Hong Kong
and then Mumbai India and leaving Mumbai
India we connected through Dubai we got
on that air Emirates that's not even an
airline it's like a W hotel with like
wings yeah it's [ __ ] unreal so that's
even like it's better than a w w was
like I'll tell you hotel like acts like
it's nice it's like nice if you were in
your 20s you see a lot of [ __ ] very
20s a lot of aquarium lighting around
the bed [ __ ] but so we were we were
thank you mentally we were upstairs
whatever all I remember was we when if
ever I went to fly that far I use all
the miles every [ __ ] thing I can
possibly do make less money yeah I'm
gonna sit at least have one of those bed
chairs and so I got up to go to the
bathroom and I walked in the back to go
to the bathroom and they had like this
semicircular bar yeah like because it
was one of those a wide-body so that was
like chair two chairs next to the window
then an aisle then the middle then an
aisle and then over so that middle
section it was as that it was that wide
in the back where it had like a
semicircle and a bartender in there and
they had a little bench seat and some
stools around their bench seat with like
a seat belt that you sat down on so I
saw it
you know up there that's where yeah and
I went back I didn't have the one girl
autograph I didn't have the one where
you had like your own apartment like
that one that one's like 15 grand one
way this so I went back and I got my
wife I said hey can I buy you a drink
she goes wait talking about go come with
me so we went to the back we were like
see and she just ear-to-ear grin and I
ordered a couple mixed drinks we sat
down on the little bench seat I put a
seat belt on put mine on and we just sat
there
we didn't have that many but it was just
so [ __ ] cool it's it didn't seem
possible it's like I'm at a bar in the
sky
I know a flying range I flying to new
you I was one of those things where I
was very excited to get back to the
states but that was definitely one that
I didn't want it to end well you just
like oh my god it's the exact opposite
of riding in coach
where it's like you can literally be
flying from like [ __ ] New York to
Buffalo do your neck start hurtin you
too sorry was sitting side by side I
don't know what you're doing you're
taking stuff out from underneath the
alright am I allowed to say what's going
on right now I don't know he took is it
legal I don't know what it is it looks
like he has let his wine I didn't think
I thought that was like liquid weed that
you could have poured to the vaporizer
and it reaches a certain temperature let
me tell you something man you're a
[ __ ] rock star because I've never had
an experience that good flying the
closest thing I ever had was I did an
18-hour flight to Australia once and I
was on the last [ __ ] flight that
allowed smoking on nine seats only on
ninth seats in no way in business class
so wasn't first class wasn't coach and
they had nine seats arranged on Qantas
for people who smoked and if I'm gonna
be 18 hours on an airplane I want a
[ __ ] cigarette you know nowadays you
got the e-cigs and it's really easy
nobody knows you're [ __ ] like
nicotine two out of your mind on these
planes I mother huffing and puffing on
my e-cig and nobody bothers me and I
don't bother anyone else but this was
the last smoking flight Qantas ever had
it was actually in the news and I was
one of the people that had those seats
and so I get there and there's this
businessman from Hong Kong next to me
and he immediately starts blowing his
nose on the tray in front of them and
there's boogers and [ __ ] all over the
seat in front of me and what his nose
and I was just like stewardess man I I
can't sit next to this [ __ ] guy okay
he's he was really weird it was rude
yeah I mean you're being really nice
about this guy to just say this it's
just to define that as a weird and rude
and and the flight was booked so they
put me in one of those kamikaze seats
that the stewardesses sit on right
before they do the little jump see
there's a little jump seat so they put
me in there so I was like all right cool
one of these does not blow er up they're
like well that's that's the point so
like I'm sitting there and I light up a
smoke and they just like flipped out
like you can't be smoking here like what
are you doing I'm like well I'm not
sitting next to that [ __ ] guy so we
had this like two hours standoff and
they tried to get the guy to move and he
wouldn't move and so they finally
acquiesced since it was the last flight
which smoking I got to sit there on the
jump seat and just change my rock star
flying story man what's with Hong Kong
you don't when I flew from Singapore to
Hong Kong I'm defensive Hong Kong this
guy might have been from Singapore he
might have been from New Hampshire I
didn't talk to him but up in the lounge
there they had they had these [ __ ]
they were making dumplings all right and
the [ __ ] dumplings that they make
over there dude and they literally they
if you dropped him they would they would
like flow plane no and I got in there in
the airport right so they keep coming
out with these dumplings this
[ __ ] keeps going up there and he
would like take seven out of eight of
them he was a skinny bastard and he was
just thought it was like remember Paul
Newman and get mad at the eggs Cool Hand
Luke he was eating him like [ __ ] Cool
Hand Luke just stick it up down his
[ __ ] throat and they were delicious
and it was just like every time they
would bring him out I would have to like
look over to make sure I could go up
there just to get some for me and my
wife so this guy must be done like
twenty or thirty I [ __ ] eat the whole
time he was up there he'd shout those
goddamn things and I don't know it kind
of put me in a mood like I was going
this is what Hong Kong's gonna be like a
bunch of selfish people eating all the
[ __ ] dumplings but then I had to
quickly be like wait a minute
wait a minute there's selfish [ __ ]
from where I'm from and I'm one of them
so maybe I'm going to the promised land
a travel review
Kong by Bilborough bunch of selfish
people eating dumplings [ __ ] this is
based on one guy who was going to Hong
Kong who I don't even know if he was
going then forget if he lived there or
if he was even Chinese
so anyways how do you watch this [ __ ]
all day MSNBC you you seem like a news
junkie yeah I'm kind of a news junkie I
I don't watch it intently but I like
keeping on as wallpaper and periodically
glance over and see like oh shits at the
fan holy crap it's been real hours and
shits at the fan it's kind of more
enjoyable with like the sound done I'm
loving this guy on the right he has the
exact same haircut is prince charles it
sticks out the exact same way it does
except he's got more hair on top if
that's his hair but what I like is that
they he's completely covered in the
graphic that the stock market is tank
today they do that to people
like if I I have to be on CNN in what
next week okay and that's my first time
oh nice so I'm gonna be in one of those
squares I just hope that stock market
hasn't completely gone to [ __ ] and I get
blame for it because that's what you'll
remember is this guy cause your stocks I
don't even know that that was about the
stock market I just look at that guy
going that guy's [ __ ] is made well
that's the haircut he you know there's
people right now that have lost their
pension because the stock markets down
and they're looking at this guy like
it's only down three hundred eighty five
bucks oh right thirty-nine dollars yeah
it's like down five hundred or something
before I don't know 500 bucks what is
500 makes I don't I don't I do and it's
the worst you can't get out of it you
can't pay attention to it you fall now I
don't I just look at it like I'll never
get that money back in whatever's left
when I'm 65 oh [ __ ] I just feel it's
it's like Las Vegas without all the
really gaudy like decorating and and
buffet food it's just like Las Vegas
I've done like I've done okay in it but
I also I invest conservatively and with
conspiracy theories over the blue-chip
now I go for like tangible [ __ ] like
people who make tangible [ __ ] I member I
invested in all these companies that
were like digging for gold and stuff
and then because I felt the dollar was
gonna collapse but then it dawned on me
one day it's just like well wait at the
end of this I don't have any gold so I
bought them a bunch of shovels and
pickaxes to give the children somewhere
to dig the side of the ground and in the
end you know I was talking what if the
[ __ ] was I talking to got a friend in
Chicago that has literally made millions
of [ __ ] dollars this is really sick
all right but I want you to listen to
this this is really emblematic of what's
going on today is this place haunted or
is that somebody hammering no that's
somebody ham okay I'm just making sure
destruction zone this guy would wait for
a mass shooting and as soon as that
happened he would invest in gun stocks
and sure enough gun stocks would go up
spike 25 points on the day like he'd
come in there and go a hundred thousand
bucks and just buy whatever gun stock
after a mass shooting within three days
he would sell it all before I went back
down and he's made millions just doing
that now it's kind of creepy but it is
this is where we're at right but I'm
trying I wouldn't try to make it that
way now wait can we do it Millie look
when let's think of another disaster
that happens when we can make some money
here every time there's a mudslide you
invest in one well I don't know
hair dryers I'm just investing in pot
futures man now that Canada's going
legal I'm all-in I'm actually gonna join
the stock market and I think solar and
wind and all these other like new tech
things are kind of a scam but I'm all
into the pot market because we saw what
like alcohol didn't 20s after the end of
prohibition and all the mega giant
corporations that came out of that like
anheuser-busch and all this and I think
pots gonna be the same thing it's not
going to be a bunch of mom pops in Marin
County it's gonna be like huge well you
ever watch the Lions you know yeah I
mean have you watched so non that was
advice set the name of the channel yeah
where they they did like putting it into
food I mean it's becoming like this
gourmet thing overnight yeah I cook I
cook pot food do you think that'll ever
happen for like heroin like today we're
making
and opiate English muffinz take like two
bites in their urine test because they
ate poppy seed muffins or so they claim
no I'll give me a [ __ ] break that's
what they claim but I'm just sayin so
there is opiate foods already been a
poppy seed muffins after they shot some
heroin that's why they [ __ ] failed
their test I used to joke about that
when people like say like oh it's you
know I'm not it's my metabolism that's
why that that's the big scapegoat my
admit AB ilysm it's really slow so yeah
that in [ __ ] 6000 calories a day
that'll make you out of shape so anyways
alright let's I think we're about dude
this is the most effortless [ __ ] 58
minutes of my life I'm so psyched that
you made another album I've heard the
one track The Twilight Zone thing I just
video out I saw the video I love that
and and the new video comes out on March
9th - not one of these like concocted by
the label lyric videos which we have no
part of and I guess they're pretty good
and kids like them and all that but we
we don't put any really input into that
that's the label just want you to get to
know the lyrics and things in the most
basic way because people have the
attention span of a [ __ ] bathroom NAT
and this and that right this next one is
is we filmed it all in the same day this
Twilight Zone video and then victims of
a clown so I haven't seen it yet I
should be able to victims of a clown
yeah should be able to see it tonight
actually we get some rushes on it and I
hope it's as good as Twilight Zone
because that one's pretty funny video
man I'm out there hanging with grey wolf
this Indian American guy I met from Aim
American Indian Movement and pretty high
level aim guy - and we're out there at
campfire just blowing harps and drinking
ayahuasca tea and it was it was great
tell me about your band you'll mention
some of the guys you got in there
yeah we got we got
I have a pretty good all-star lineup
it's Joey Jordison playing drums with us
his tour Burton bells helped me Joey
Jordan from from Jordans them from us
not yeah
Burton Bell from Fear Factory has helped
me on the vocals this time and Tony
Campos from old static-x and asesino
about a billion other bouncies in is on
bass and then a two usual guitar players
sync we're in and sees our Soto which
are awesome John Bechdel which has been
with us for about eight years and he
comes from Killing Joke and the early
Killing Joke days and and then DJ
swamped from Beck this is what's awesome
this way I witness when are you gonna
put your tour dates up cuz I gotta see
you guys life there right there up
what's your website first ministry no
calm or some [ __ ] I don't know I'm not
the best promo sexual you yeah I'm
finding that I'm finding it alright but
al has a new album out his band's called
ministry by it somewhere and he has a
website that has the name ministry in it
something like that and he is on tour
and somewhere those dates are available
it's like a treasure map and at the end
you get the pot of gold just find it
it's just white ministry and either
you'll get put to some Billy Graham
webpage or you'll get put to us but I
know that somewhere you'll wind up on
our page and you'll figure [ __ ] out okay
well dude you're one of my favorite
people I always love talking to you and
it's an honor that you wanted to come
onto my podcast to promote your album if
I hope that you wanted to and it wasn't
your label making you do this and this
has been an uncomfortable hour doesn't
even know about this okay this is you
and then we're just gonna spring it on
and go [ __ ] you so what do you think
format nothing we did we have this
famous guy to come over I don't know
about that I have a little notoriety I
don't know what I'm saying you know it's
right here this is not label sanctioned
alright so last thing
what are you want you Blackhawks doing I
barely watch hockey this year my Bruins
have made all these moves we bought you
know a couple guys from off the day you
got your conscience you got winged goals
from us a nice fourth line guy for you
guys you guys we got a Nashville
yeah yeah you got national rain Jersey
you guys are looking good I mean and and
this is good for Boston you needed this
because when when Claude Julien was your
coach and [ __ ] you guys were up down
this [ __ ] I love them I love them yeah
but it was real bipolar there for a
while he did lead us to our first Cup in
40 years so I I know I know because we
had three of them my Chicago Blackhawks
in there so we tied it up and then you
guys [ __ ] I know you guys tied it up
and then you funny ten yeah that was
good no boy well for me anyways but uh
yeah we're tanking right now thank God
it's time to like get some new blood I
mean the the general manager Stan Bowman
his first year after the first Cup and
he made the rookie mistake of a GM and
just like well of course
Chicago hadn't had a cup in like
40-something years everyone's like we
gotta keep this team forever and you
know everyone thinks that they're all
junkies and they're gonna look the same
twenty years from now what's the run and
and so he overpaid all these people
locked him in with no trade contracts
and [ __ ] and now we're stuck with all
these decaying old guys that don't do
enough hair Seabrook still playing for
you guys oh yeah I think I mean he's out
there that's the best number in hockey
seven yeah what an individual's nine
nine and seven hides a good one too any
any like a single-digit one yeah it's
cool but those all got retired cuz all
the best guys had them so now like the
big things to have the double yeah
seventy-seven 99-88 all of that [ __ ]
alright cool well thank you so much for
coming on the podcast I can't wait to
hear the new album and furthermore I
can't wait to see you guys live if
you're doing a full show I will come out
on a toy drum set we got we get the
double bass pedal we got March 22nd or
so on Anaheim and March 23rd and Ventura
and I'll ok on drums at one of those
shows if you can fit it in your schedule
that'd be awesome absolutely but I don't
I don't know that I'm gonna be able to
pull my double bass play I'm just start
no we'll give you an easy song to play
house that will give you something and
and we won't [ __ ] with you too hard I
promise
hey it's your show man I don't give a
[ __ ] you want to [ __ ] with me [ __ ] with
me just the fact that I'll get to do it
will be awesome all right
thank you so much and everybody thank
you for listening and I'll check in on
you on Thursday
thanks ma'am